study on this morning adds to concerns
about some common painkillers the
research is reported in the british
journal of clinical pharmacology it
looks at prescription non-steroid
anti-inflammatory drugs so think of
prescription-strength ibuprofen and
naproxen doctors call them NSAIDs people
taking the pain relievers had an 18%
higher risk of irregular heartbeat
earlier studies linked over-the-counter
insets to a bigger chance of heart
attacks and strokes or dr. tehrani rule
is a cardiologist at northwell health
and joins us at the table to discuss is
this as scary as it sounds because I
know a lot of us take naproxen well it's
important information for people because
these are commonly used drugs things as
you mentioned like ibuprofen naproxen
celebrex that we use for arthritis
headaches muscle joint pain but in this
study what researchers did is they
looked at about 50,000 middle-aged
Taiwanese individuals who reported using
prescription doses of NSAIDs and they
looked to see if there was an increased
risk of atrial fibrillation which is an
irregular heart rhythm and they did
indeed find an association now a fib
means the top chambers of the heart beat
chaotically that can increase your risk
of stroke and heart failure it is amiss
beyond this they're unsure the thinking
is that possibly it changes blood flow
to the kidneys raises the blood pressure
causes imbalances in potassium stretches
the top chambers of the heart and that
can trigger the atrial fibrillation in
this study was conducted both men and
women it was yes a general population in
Taiwan and so what does that take away
for people even taking aspirin I mean
should people be concerned about
something as common as aspirin that
people take on a daily basis well
aspirin is in the class of non-steroidal
anti-inflammatories but it is different
than some of the ones we're talking
about and so we all know about aspirin
for use in the setting of cardiovascular
disease and at those doses 81 milligrams
325 there's still an increased risk of
bleeding gastrointestinal bleeding in
the brain but when you're talking about
using aspirin for pain and in
anti-inflammatory effects you're talking
about much higher doses like six hundred
and fifty milligrams to eight thousand
milligrams and at those doses you are
really increasing your risk of hearing
loss gastrointestinal bleeding kidney
failure and other significant side
effects and that's over-the-counter
aspirin that you were talking about just
then yes and so I think we need to be
clear about over
the counter drugs okay and in this NSAID
class they also have a warning label on
them okay that says that they can
increase the risk of heart attack and
stroke we know that as a class this is
an effect of these drugs but people
don't read their label reader labels
however the FDA says that if you use the
over-the-counter NSAIDs as indicated
which means for less than ten days for
pain low-dose short time it's generally
safe the problem is a lot of Americans
don't read the labels and they don't use
them that way they take their naproxen
every day from their pill that they have
in their medicine cabinet for years or
they may take higher doses so it's
important to read the labels but I want
to be clear this study was prescription
and sets not over-the-counter NSAIDs no
we should point out from the Consumer
Healthcare Products Association they say
this that the study only looked at
prescription medicines and did not
include over-the-counter medicines which
are used in smaller doses for shorter
durations right and so that's exactly
what we're saying but in 2015 the FDA
required prescription makers event sets
to change their labeling to say they can
cause heart attack and stroke the risk
increases the longer you take them the
higher the dose and that risk can happen
in the first few weeks and they
requested that over-the-counter
manufacturers change their labels so
clearly this is a class effect yeah
that's why it's important to know about
it all right read your labels talk to
your doctor yeah thanks